Now fast forward to 2012.
We built the Google Car.
We're now using multiple methods.
We use histogram methods and particle methods.
The main difference to what you've learned, so far, is two-fold.
The main difference that we've learned so far
is the Robot Model.
The vehicle is actually modeled as a system
with 2 non-steerable wheels and 2 steerable wheels.
That's often called a Bicycle Model
because half of it--this thing over here--
acts like a bicycle.
The big difference is the Sensor Data.
Instead of using landmarks,
we get this really elaborate road map,
and then we take a single snapshot
and we match that snapshot into the map.
And the better the match,
the higher the score.
And then on top of it, we have additional sensors, like GPS.
We also have Inertial Sensors.
I am not going to go into those at all,
but the methods I taught you
are rich enough to handle these additional sensors.
So you've just learned about the gist of the method
the method in which the Google Car is able
to find where it is, and where other cars are.
When you build a system, you have to
dive into these more elaborate methods
But I think it's very much doable.
It's very easy to replace
the current simple motion model with the slightly
more sophisticated, for what's called
a Bicycle Model, and it's easy to write
a correlation function of the map data
and computes normalized correlations
of measurement images in a big pixel map.
I'll leave this an an exercise
so if you want to hack your own car
and make it drive itself, have fun.
I just want to congratulate you.
You've actually, in these 3 classes,
learned pretty much as much as
any of my Stanford student learns
in my Specialized AI classes on robotics, when it comes to robot perception.
In fact, you've learned pretty much what there is to know
to become a successful practitioner in robotics.